>> FRYZEL: Welcome to Boot Camp. And I hope
you're having a very good time here. My name
is Vic. I'm an engineer on Google Docs. I'm
going to give a talk today about how to store
all of your data in Google's Cloud. So if
you have any questions or anything, we're
going to have a question-and-answer session
at the end of the talk. But if you, you know,
just don't think of your question now or whatever,
you can hit me up on Twitter or Buzz. There's
my Twitter name right there. So, let's get
started. This is my SpeakerMeter tag. If you
want to scan this now and browse that URL,
and--you can rate me as I speak or whatever.
And I'll get some indication as to how great
my speaking abilities are or how much they
suck. So--oh, let me go back. I saw some people
scanning it. Okay. So to start off, we all
know that there's a lot of cloud services
nowadays that offer the ability to store data.
This is nothing new. This has been around
for quite a long time. I mean, if you think
back to it, the first cloud storage really
existed in maybe the late '80s or early '90s
where you had the--this idea of a mainframe;
and you could upload data there via some means
and then consume it in some other means. But
usually, there is this idea that you uploaded
data to be processed. And when you uploaded
data to be processed, you did it because the
terminals with which you were uploading this
data or submitting this data were actually
weak in terms of power and the power is concentrated
into the mainframe. So, this--or this idea
is sort of recurring today. So, developers
need the ability to do more than just store
the data; they actually need the ability to
process large amounts of data in a, you know,
short amount of time. So, we're starting to
move back to this idea of putting data in
the cloud, and then having thousands of computers
act on it, and then giving you setbacks and
meaningful result. Users also have more needs
of this data. So, they need to be able to
be access and manipulate the data from pretty
much anywhere, so--in lots of different ways.
I mean, a majority of data is actually documents;
things that users add-on on a regular basis,
especially in an enterprise environment, right?
So--I mean, in an enterprise environment,
you have docs, calendars, things like that,
that people use every single day. In a consumer
setting, there's actually a lot of these as
well. People manage their photos, their contacts,
other personal information; and they store
all of these data traditionally nowadays in
the cloud. But if we take a look at everything
that somebody's doing there's a large portion
of it being done in documents. So, let's compare
options for storing cloud data. Firstly, we
have offline doc--documents, and this is--this
is pretty basic concept, right? I'm pretty
sure that I remember, like two decades ago
working in Microsoft Office and using offline
docs. So, that was okay. I had the ability
to edit documents. But there wasn't really
built-in collaboration or sharing, and there
wasn't any sense that these documents were
accessible from anywhere. And I also had a
whole lot of trouble converting between formats.
So, I remember having lots of trouble converting
the things like PDFs or, you know, for a long
time, other office formats. So this was actually
a pretty limited option. And even today, if
you want to share something from an offline
document system, you traditionally attach
it to an email and send it off. So, that's
actually not a very good way to share things
at all. So skipping Google Docs for a minute
and moving on to the traditional cloud storage.
Traditional cloud storage is actually kind
of dumb, in that; here, we can upload things
and access them from anywhere but we can't
do anything with that data, right? So, users
can't do things like edit documents, there's
no built-in collaboration or sharing, and
lastly, it's really hard to convert things
between formats. But Google Docs actually
does a lot of these things. So, it fits a
use case of a cloud storage platform; because
it does all of these things and also gives
you cloud services to act on your data. So,
going into Google Docs in a little bit more
detail. This is your Google Documents list.
So, just a quick show of hands, who uses Google
Docs? I think every single person in the room
raised their hand. So that's fantastic. So
you're familiar with this, right? You have
collections, you have, you know, all of your
files and documents there or you can store
things. It's really easy to share. So, this
is a really standard interface for accessing
all of the stuff you put in Google Docs. So,
for those of you who might not know, your
documents list can actually contain more than
just documents. It can contain videos, spreadsheets,
any other file type and collections. So, videos;
we actually recently added support for playing
videos in your documents list. So, if you
upload a video of like, your kids playing
or something, you can watch that. And we also
support uploading other file types as well
now. So you can upload any way an audio recording
you made or a ZIP file, things like that.
So, they can upload or download anything in
the Google Docs interface. So, what we wanted
to start to look at now is you doing that
in a programmatic matter, right? With the
Google Documents List API. So who here has
used the Google Documents List API? I see
like maybe, five, six people. If you're not
using this API and your applications need
cloud storage, you should definitely consider
using this API. For a large number of reasons
that I'm going to go through. But today, what
we're going to do in detail is go through
example of working with the Documents List
API, and give you an introduction into using
this API. And this introduction is for the
main I/O talk about the Google Documents List
API and I/O on Wednesday. So, the Documents
List API allows your application to do pretty
much anything you can do in the Google Docs
UI. So, you can upload files, you can download
files, you can store items, move items between
collections, create collections; all of the
stuff. So, really, the API allows your applications
to act as if they were a user in the UI. Some
of the basic features; you can store any type
of data. This is new. Previously, you could
not store any type of data with the API; so
now, you can store any type of data. You can
also securely share data. So, secure sharing
is actually a really important feature of
Google Docs, in that you can share something
with someone without sending it via plain
text email. So, to be--to be clear here, if
you use a traditional offline document or
an offline file, like let's say you want to
send a text file to your friend in New York.
If you were to do that and you emailed it
to them, the email is most likely going to
be in plain text, and the attachment is also
going to be in plain text. So, there are things
you can do. Like, you could encrypt the email;
but generally, people find encrypting email
to be inaccessible and not a lot of people
know how to do that. But people know how to
go into Google Docs and they know how to click
share. And so when you do this, what happens
is, an email gets sent off to your friends;
and it's a sharing email with no sensitive
information in the email unless you choose
to include the item in the email. So then,
the user has to click on a link and then go
to Google Docs. And all of this time, they've
been acting via HTTPS; and all of the transactions
are secure. So, you don't have to worry about
things being stolen, like that. Also with
the API, you can manage collections. I'm going
to go into that in a little bit. So, who uses
API? Just give you some example use cases.
Here are three example use cases. The first
one is Memeo. Memeo builds this product called
Memeo Connect. And it essentially connects
all of your individual devices to the Google
Cloud and syncs things back and forth. They
also give a back-up product. Syncplicity does
something similar but in a more desktops-oriented
setting. So, syncplicity has a sync client
for your desktop, and it can sync different
portions of your hard drive very easily to
the cloud. So here, we have two products that
are actually pretty successful; and what they
do is sync things to the cloud. And lastly,
we have Google Doc--the Google Docs app for
Android. So, the Google Docs app for Android
is new. Has anybody used this? Yes, it's sick,
right? I really like this app a lot. This
actually also uses a Documents List API. So,
what it's doing is, from your Android phone,
it's essentially Java application that uses
our Java client library and makes request
to the API on a regular basis on behalf of
a user to request a list of documents or let
you interact with those documents. So, those
are three use cases. So, more popular use
cases are definitely, like I said, synchronization
but backups to the Cloud. So I personally,
on my workstation at home, I set up a--I used
to have like an Rsync script set up. But what
I realized was I had to have like an SSH client
wherever I was to access my documents from
my like, web server. And that wasn't really
convenient. So, I started synching my documents
to my Google Docs in my files. And in doing
this, I can actually access my files from
anywhere. So that's really useful. You don't
need any special clients or anything to access
your data. Also, document editing. Some people
prefer to implement their own document editors
and actually use Google Docs as the storage
for the data. So, there are a lot of products
that, you know, for instance implement their
own web versions of spreadsheet or they build
a sync client between Microsoft Office and
Google Docs. And in those cases, document
editing is actually use case for this; but
the storage is all handled by the Documents
List API. Also, revision management. I've
seen people implement wikis and corporate
intranets and things like that. So, it's really
easy to edit text in Google Docs. So, doing
something like a corporate intranet or a wiki
is really simple and you can manage all of
those revisions yourself through the Documents
List API. So, we're going to get started developing
apps now. So, the documentation is at this
Google link. So, I don't know if anybody cares
to write that down. But essentially, the documentation
is a complete guide on how to do every single
thing with the API. We're not really going
to go through the documentation today which
is why I'm giving you the link. I'm going
to go through some more advanced use cases.
They're in the documentation, but are much
better explained in person. So this is just
a screenshot of the documentation. So you
can see here, it's laid out in a use case-oriented
manner. So, if you need to, for instance,
create a collection or create a sub-collection,
or learn how to upload a drawing or download
a spreadsheet; all of those things are here
and described in detail. But again, I'm not
going to walk through the documentation today.
Instead, I want to go through some specific
key words and terminology before we move in
to actually writing code. So, for the purpose
of this talk; and when you're working with
Documents List API, a document is any entry
that's editable in Google Docs. So, don't
think text document here; think spreadsheet,
drawing, presentation, text document is also
one. But this is just something that you can
edit in Google Docs via the Web UI. Whereas
a file is something that cannot be edited
in the Google Docs UI, okay? Does everybody
understand the distinction? So, a file is
not a document. It means, when you upload
it, it's just there for storage, you can't
yet edit it in Google Docs. A collection is
something that contains other entries. So,
a collection is kind of like a folder; and
it's kind of like a label. We actually used
to call these "Things Folders", but we realized
that that's not a really good name because
people have some predisposition of what a
folder is. So, a collection is like a folder,
in that, it has a hierarchy. So, you can put
a collection inside of another collection,
okay? So, kind of like a folder in that regard.
But it's like a label in the sense that a
document or a file can belong to more than
one collection, okay? So, you could apply
a collection as a label to 10 documents, okay?
And then, you can apply a different label
to those same 10 documents. So, we've kind
of merged the idea of a folder and a label
into one thing and we call it a collection.
If you don't understand how those two things
work together, you can more or less think
of these as a folder though. Lastly, a resource
is any of the three things that I've previously
described. So, the API works in such a manner
that things are abstracted out so that you
can change the title of a collection just
like you would change the title of a document.
And we try to make it really easy. So, a resource
refers to any of those three things. So, who
in the room knows Java? Almost everybody.
Who in the room knows Python? Less people.
Okay. So, I'm going to go through some Java
samples and then some Python samples. But
if you don't know one or the other, you should
be able to follow along. If not, all of these
things can be figured out pretty easily with
the documentation or you can just ask me later.
So here, what we're doing is we're creating
a new URL. And the Documents List API is a
REST-based API. Everybody knows REST? Yes.
If you don't know REST, there's other talks
on it here. But essentially, what it--what
it means is, it's a single endpoint that allows
you to create, retrieve, update and delete
resources. So here, we have the single endpoint;
and if we do an HTTP GET request, we can fetch
a list of documents. And if we do an HTTP
POST, we can create a new document or file.
So here, I'm creating a new URL and then I'm
fetching that URL into a feed. And the feed
here is just like a list of resources. And
then, for each resource in that list, I'm
just printing out its title. So this is like
the Hello World of Documents List API, right?
You're just fetching a list of documents in
files and then printing them out. Everybody
understand what's going on here? Cool. So,
here's a much more complex example. Here is
an example of uploading your existing documents.
So, let's just walk through this really quick.
The only line here that really matters is
the top line because this is what's calling
the method we defined below. So here, we're
calling uploadFile and then "/path/to/your/file.doc"
and then we're giving it a title. So, after
that, we print out where the document ended
up, you know, on Google Docs and you can give
that link to a user for instance to click
on and then access it in Google Docs. So the
uploadFile method is where all the interesting
stuff happens. We could have new Java file
objects based on the given path, and then
we find out its MIME type. So, these are pretty
much the two things required to upload a document.
You need to know the path of the file on your
hard drive, and you need to know its type.
So if you wanted to upload a text document,
you don't want to upload it for instance as
a presentation. Then lastly, what we're going
to do is create a new Documents List API entry.
We're going to set the file to the file we
just created, and then we're going to set
its title, and then lastly, we're going to
do the HTTP POST request to insert this at
that endpoint. So, long story short, we found
the file on the hard drive, we determine its
MIME type, and then we send it to Google Doc--the
Google Documents List API. And now, the Google
Documents List API is going to take it from
there. It's going to interpret your document,
convert it to a Google Docs format, and then
make it editable in the Web UI. So, I don't
know what is this, 20 lines of code and we're
uploading stuff and having it converted automatically.
It--it's pretty nice. So, another example.
Remember I said documents are not files. If
you want to upload something and make sure
that does--it does not get converted, you
can use convert=false. So we won't convert
it if we don't know how to convert it. But
if you wanted to, for instance, upload a text
file and make it not editable via a user,
you could do convert=false. So there are lots
of reasons to do this; maybe you only want
this file editable on the user's hard drive
and not from Google Docs or something like
that. So, convert=false. So, you would us
this to upload a ZIP file or, you know, an
mp3 file maybe, something like that. So, that's
all pretty simple. I just want to get a little
bit more advanced now. So, I want to get a
little bit more advanced with this use case.
How do you turn an image of text into text
that you can edit? Ideas, anybody? You can
shout them out. So, who in the audience knows
about OCR? Cool. So, we're going to go through
OCR a little bit today; and how you can implement
it with one line of code. So, OCR stands for
Optical Character Recognition. And essentially,
what this allows you to do if you implement
it properly is turn an image of text, which
is a set of pixels, into a textual representation.
So, in this case, we have that stop sign and
everybody here knows that it says, "Stop."
But does the computer know that it says, "Stop"?
And so, Optical Character Recognition allows
us, via a series of algorithms, to turn it
into a text file, right? That we can edit.
So, we can edit those characters. Now, this
brings up a whole bunch of important points.
Firstly, can somebody tell me, what is the
paragraph style of a stop sign? Anybody know?
No, right? So, it's pretty confusing. What
is the paragraph style of a stop sign? So,
OCR has to do a lot of analysis on how to
make this show up correctly in a document.
It's one thing to turn it into text; it's
another thing to make sure that all of the
letters are capitalized and that it shows
up in the correct paragraph setting, right?
So, Google Docs actually allows you to do
this very easily. So, we would take all of
the previous code and just change it so that
we say, ocr=true at the end of the URL. And
that's it. Now, when Google Docs gets to the
file, it's going to use Optical Character
Recognition on the file and turn it into an
editable document. So, this is pretty sick.
And this is like my favorite feature. So,
we're going to take a look at how we do this
in action. So, let me pull up TextMate. So,
here, I have a Python program that I wrote.
And the sole purpose of this Python Program
is to upload an image and get text back, okay?
So, if you're not familiar with Python--oops,
I'm used to using them, so you can see me
type JK there. You can--if we scroll through
with it--if you're not used to using Python,
here, I'm just putting a shebang saying this
should run with the Python interpreter, and
then copyright comments, whatever. Then the
imports. These imports are used in a variety
of ways. But the important one here is that
we're importing the gdata docs API client.
So, all these means is that we, at Google,
write a Python client library and then we
give it to you for free. And the purpose of
this library is to make these HTTP requests
that I talked about for you. So, we have the
equivalent in Java, in .Net, in PHP. So, if
you're using any of those languages, using
the API should be really simple. So, here,
I'm importing the Python one, and I'm going
to write an upload method. So, I'm just going
to create a docs client; and all this is is
some class that makes these HTTP requests
very simple. And then, I'm going to log in.
So here, I'm using client login with the user
name and password. This is my test account.
If you login and delete stuff, that will just
annoy me. So next, we're going to get that
base URL we talked about. So, that's like
the feed and stuff of all private flow of
things that you saw before. Now, we're going
to iterate over a list of files; and for each
file, we're going to do some stuff. Just because
I was lazy, I didn't, like, detect the MIME
type, I just assumed that you're using a JPEG
file. We're going to append that ocr=true
flag to the end of the URL. And then, we're
going to open up the file, read it into some
file container that's part of the client library,
and then we're going to decode client.Upload.
So, this is about 10 lines of code; and we
just uploaded a file with OCR in Python. The
rest of this--oh, actually, at the end of
this method, what it does is it prints out
success; and then, the URL at which we could
access the new editable document on the web.
The rest of this is just like some option
parsing stuff; that's not really relevant.
We're just going to pass in the list of files.
So, if I come back here, you can see me testing
out some random data. So, I have this directory
with a couple of things in it. docslist.py,
I'm sorry, that's red and green for some of
you, is the file that we're going to run and
we're going to do this pass in -f stop.jpg.
So, I just put it out the options that we
passed in there, make sure they're parsed
correctly. Success. So, I just write a command,
upload--uploaded it to the Google Cloud, and
converted it to text. This is going to be
amazing if I can find Firefox. Hold on one
second. Apparently, I never learned how to
copy and paste. Why is that not working? Search
Bookmarks and History. Okay. That's looks
more I like it. All right. So, here, we have
the original stop sign image. So, we just
include this in the document so you know what
you converted; but you can easily remove this
from the document just by converting the document
to like, a raw plain text file and then the
image will be thrown away. And then down here,
this little word is what I've been looking
for. So, this word, I can edit. I can insert
stuff into it. It's raw text. So it read the
stop sign, put it in the correct character
case, and then put it in the correct paragraph
style down here. So, that's pretty crazy.
But that's kind of a silly example, because
not many people are like, "Hmm, I wonder if
the stop sign says, 'stop'." So, instead,
what we're going to do is look at a little
bit more of an advanced sample. Look--the
question was, will it also do font style?
And the answer is no, not at this time; because
we don't have the stop sign font registered,
sorry. So, here's another one. This is from
the University of Texas. I really don't know
what's about; I just like, searched for it
on the web. And it says, "In July 1845 Texas
formally accepted an American proposal to
be annexed to the United States." I guess
that's kind of important. So, anybody from
Texas? Woohoo. All right. So, we're going
to convert this into a textual form; and then
we could do something like, put it on our
blog in text form so that it's searchable,
people can copy and paste it much more easily,
things like that. We can change the font if
we wanted to. So, this is called text1.jpg.
Let me go back to our terminal. And after
come up, and instead of stop, let me do text1.jpg.
So, it just takes a second. And there we go.
So, it's uploaded and converted. This is all
live. I didn't--I didn't have some master
plan to fool you all. Let me go back to Firefox,
new tab and open this up. So, here's the original
image, right? This is not editable, right?
If I delete this image, the whole image goes
away. And down here, I'm not sure if you can
see this; but in--well, that was kind of slow.
In July 1845, something, something, something,
Texas was annexed. So, that's pretty [INDISTINCT],
right? I just took an image off of my hard
drive, uploaded it through the Cloud, and
then had Google's thousands of computers operate
on your one file, and convert it into raw
editable text like this. So, yes. Yes, cool.
So, actually, I have a lot of international
friends especially now that I work at Google.
It seems like, you know, half the company
works in a different office. And on occasion,
I have no idea what the hell people are saying,
because they speak in different language than
I do. So, this is something that we can resolve
at Google Docs. What we're going to do is
show that OCR isn't actually just limited
to English. So if I comeback to find her,
and I look in text2, let me zoom in here.
I don't speak German. Does anybody speak German?
All right. So, this is some German text. I
don't really know what it says, but I'm going
to find out, right? Because I'm going to convert
it away from this image into OCR. And then
if I wanted to, I could use the translate
features of the API to translate that text
to English or vice versa. So, if we come back
to the terminal, I've got this in text2.jpg.
I can upload text2. And just give it a minute.
It takes like, extra long for German. Just
kidding. Sorry. Do you have a question?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FRYZEL: The question is: Are you limited
to the Roman alphabet? No, we do support other
character sets. And that will become evident
because--I mean, there are some English characters
that do not show up or, like--I only know
French ones like [SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
for instance. It's not part of my U.S. keyboard.
So it's not just like an ASCII character set
or anything like that. Okay. So, if I copy
this and then I go back to Firefox. Now, that
we have these English texts converted with
OCR, is change this whole use case just a
little bit. It's really good that we have
OCR for, you know, the ASCII character set.
But actually, our OCR implementation, I can
go quite a bit further. And so, what we do
allow is for the conversion of the--of like,
other languages essentially. So, let's take
an example that I have here of text2.jpg.
And so, if I zoom in here, you can see that
text2.jpg is in German. So--actually, does
anybody in the audience know German? Two people.
Cool. Okay. So maybe you guys can read this
because I can't. But that's okay because what
I'm going to do is turn this image of German
text into an editable form. And then after
it's editable, what we can do are some things
like translation. So this is text2.jpg's.
So let me pull up my terminal here. We'll
just find it here. And let me pull up my other
terminal. Sorry. So, here, we have the previous
command that we just ran. So docslist.py-f
text1.jpg, that was for the English version.
Now we have text2.jpg, so let's just run that.
So it's going to take a second here while
it uploads and converts; but if we just give
it one more second. Oh, there. Okay. So, we
now have the converted form of the image here.
So let me go back to Firefox. And if I pop
this up. So if I scroll down, oop, there's
the--there's the German image. Remember, we
said the original image shows up just so we
can tell what we converted. And then if I
scroll down further with compact controls
on. I scroll down further. Click that image
out of there. We actually now have the editable
text here, right? So, this came straight out
of the image. And you can see it's actually
pretty high quality; and the paragraph form
is intact. So if I scroll down further, you
can see like here nothing is out of place.
The first line is where it's supposed to be.
So now, we can go a step further, right? Like,
if we, for instance, pull up this English
version of the text and I want to convert
it, say, for my friend in Japan, what I can
actually do is go to tools, translate document,
and then I can just choose a language. Let
me choose Japanese here. Does anybody in the
audience actually know Japanese? No? Okay.
Well, my friend does, so. I'm going to translate
it. And, boom. So, we've actually now got
the fully translated version; and it's editable
so I don't have other right character set.
But you can see that I can make changes to
the document just like any other document.
So, that's pretty huge, right? So, now that
we've been able to do that from the UI, we
can actually also do it via the API. And it's
really simple. Instead of saying OCR=true,
you're just going to say translate=true. It's
the API. So, it's pretty straightforward.
So, yes, that's pretty much it for that sample.
Let's go back to the presentation. Oops. I'm
not showing you in Firefox. So, this has just
really been an introduction to one of our
most powerful services. I just wanted to take
another quick survey. Who in the audience
uses Documents List API? Well, yes. So there
were a lot of people. If you're not--again,
this is definitely an API you should be considering
if you're doing any form of cloud storage;
that we provide both the storage and the services
on top of that data to make your life as a
developer easier. So, if you're really interested
in the Google Docs APIs in a more advanced
use case, you should definitely come and check
out my main IO talk on a similar topic. It's
May 11th; so this Wednesday, from 12:30 to
1:30 in Room 2 at IO. So at the talk, we're
actually going to change the use case a little
bit and go through writing a full application.
So, we're going to start talking about things
like; how do you build an app engine app with
the Documents List API? How do you implement
3-legged OAuth with the API? How do you use
something like Javascript in HTML5 to upload
files? Things like that. So, it's going to
be really, really interesting full-fledged
app, and we're going to go through all of
the codes. So, it's going to be a very technical
topic. So--yes, please attend that. Here's
my SpeakerMeter QR code again. If you're interested
in giving me feedback on the talk, please
let me know. It's right there. Also, the documentation
is at that Google link, so went through documentation
a little bit. But if you're interested in
implementing any of these use cases, definitely
just go take a look. Also, we have a really
thriving inactive forum community in which
myself and Rob, who's in the audience--we're
both engineers on Google Docs, and we post
in there on a regular basis. So, when you
post in the forum, you're actually essentially
emailing us; and we'll email you back. So,
definitely check out the forum if you have
any questions or if you just want to show
off something cool that you've done, that's
all a good idea. So, now, I wanted to open
it up for questions.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FRYZEL: It's not a limitation of the abilities
of the document type, we just haven't implemented
it yet. That's all. Other questions? Yes?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FRYZEL: Yes. So, the question is, does
the Documents List API support speech to text?
Is that essentially your question? Yes. The
answer is no, but primary because that doesn't
have a lot to do with storage at the moment.
However, if you are going to write, for instance,
a web application or an Android application,
there is this new HTML5 speech input. And
the speech input allows you to convert speech
to text. So, if you wanted to have somebody,
you know, for instance narrate a document,
and just have everything they say pop up in
a--in a Google Doc, you could do this pretty
easily. So, in an HTML5 app, you would use
the input speech type; and on an Android app,
there's the whole speech API. So, that is
definitely doable. So, the Documents List
API more or less just handles the storage
end or the conversion end from a--from a non-speech
perspective. Yes. Other questions? Yes?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FRYZEL: Yes.
>> FRYZEL: Yes, yes. So, the question is,
she's building a knowledge management system,
and they're building a gadget in sites that
uploads documents. And on occasion, the documents
that for users to upload are too large? That's
your question? So, we have the Metadata feed
and that tells you the maximum file size of
varying types of documents. So, for various
reasons, we have maximum file sizes. Some
of those reasons just involve things like
users abusing the system. And we want to avoid
people abusing the system, just using it for
legit causes. So, that's one reason. But if
you run into a specific file size limitation,
there are a couple of best practices. One,
you may consider splitting up the file into
separate parts. I mean, you can upload any
type of file you want. So, if I took, for
instance, a Microsoft Word file, and I literally
cut it in half at the byte and then have,
you know, now two distinct files and I upload
both of those, and then later on I merge them
back together, that's fine. Things like that.
But for documents that are converted, you
shouldn't really have any issues. We have
a very generous quota for things like that.
So, I'm not sure I answered your question,
but I'm happy talk afterward. We can go through
specifically your application. Other questions?
I take you first.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FRYZEL: Yes.
>> FRYZEL: Yes. So, the question was, can
I just upload an HTML file and add my own
editor for the HTML?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FRYZEL: Yes. So--I mean, in that particular
case, you would probably just upload the HTML
file and say convert=false. And if you do
that, we won't try to convert it to something
editable; and you can just build your own
editor on top of that with no issues.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FRYZEL: I'm sorry. I can't hear you.
>> FRYZEL: Oh. The thing that you're referring
to--you're referring to like an "Open with"
thing, right? Like on a--I think on Mac, you
can right-click on something like "Open with"?
Like "Open with" some arbitrary application?
Is that what you mean? That's something that
we're considering. And I don't have any other
information to give at this point. Other questions?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FRYZEL: So, the question is, are there
any plans to convert character-based files
to--oh, vector-based. Well, actually, we already
support SVG imports. So, you can create an
SVG file, upload that to us, and we'll turn
it into a drawing for you. So, that's fully
supported. We're working on some other import
formats from different file types, but SVG
is definitely the best one so far. Other questions?
Yes.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FRYZEL: No.
>> FRYZEL: How did you--the API was. I work
on spreadsheets; and I will gladly talk to
you about this after the talk. Yes. But the
short answer is, no. Not at this moment. Other
questions? Yes.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FRYZEL: Yes.
>> FRYZEL: Yes. The question is, what about
version control and collaborative editing?
So, in Google Docs, what we do--I mean, we
pretty much live and breathe collaborative
something. So, collaborative editing is what
Google Docs does really, really well. And
those changes are handled by operational transforms.
So, when there's a conflict, essentially,
we--for conversion. Here, the Google Documents
List API provides you a list of those versions;
and you can actually create, retrieve, update,
and delete versions of a specific document.
So, you actually have full control over the
versioning of any document or file. Does that
make sense? Yes. Okay. Other questions? Yes.
>> For a version change, is that change [INDISTINCT]
>> FRYZEL: No.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FRYZEL: Yes. You can say "Google Docs API,
here is a new version of this file. Please
create one for me and--" yes. All right. Other
questions? Yes.
>> [INDISTINCT] some of those have access
to the API [INDISTINCT] Can you guys sort
of [INDISTINCT] to it [INDISTINCT]? For example,
you make application and [INDISTINCT] the
history [INDISTINCT].
>> FRYZEL: The history. That's a really good
question. The question was, can a malicious
user log into the API or like, access using
the API and model with revision history and
then make changes that nobody knows about?
The answer is that no, that wouldn't really
work because there's always going to be a
latest revision; and the latest revision will
give you a--essentially, a history of everything
that changed up to that revision. So, if they
deleted the latest revision, you'd be left
with the original. So, that really, I don't
think would work out. Yes.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FRYZEL: They could delete that revision
but revision's changes have already been applied
in Revision 7. So, it's still going to be
there. You can't maliciously add data and
get rid of the paper trail. Yes. Yes?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FRYZEL: Yes. You could say .json and then...
>> FRYZEL: Yes. You can update the contents
of that file. If you send a create request
each time, you'd end up with like 100 JSON
files. But if you find this particular JSON
file, you can change its contents with new
stuff. Yes. Anything else? Yes, sorry.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FRYZEL: Yes.
>> FRYZEL: Yes. You wouldn't need a public
Docs account. So, the API supports access
control lists, which I refer to as ACLs. And
so, you actually have full control over that--over
a document's ACL. So, you can--I forget the
specific use case. But the question was, how
do I essentially create a public repository
of documents. You would upload all of these
documents; and then, you can mark them public
to the world so that you just need the link
to find the document. And then, you show the
link with whoever who wants it. You can also
be much less restrictive than that--or much
less generous in that with your sharing. You
could share to like, these specific people,
these people with--that only have this link,
things like that. Anything else? Okay. So,
again, my name is Vic. I'll be around BootCamp
today and throughout all of I/O. This is Rob.
He'll be around same thing. If you have any
questions about the Documents List API or
Docs in general, feel free to find us and
just ask as anything. All right. Thank you.